yeah all right well something you can do
this memorial day while you're lounging
around at home is some self-care elia
clean beauty the sponsors of this
segment shows us how
look around clean beauty brands and
natural makeup are more popular than
ever and it makes sense i'm anna d'souza
i've been a beauty reporter for almost
15 years and i've been lucky enough to
preview beauty innovations from brands
from across the globe and i have to say
ilia beauty checks all the boxes known
for its clean skin enhancing products
ilia just came out with a first of its
kind breakthrough formula c beyond
triple serum spf 40 and they found a way
to combine three active skin care
ingredients vitamin c mineral spf 40 and
niacinamide together in one bottle so
you're getting skin care spf and glow
you won't have to worry about that white
ghost looking cast you typically get
from mineral spf cbons comes in three
translucent tones that literally melt
into your skin leaving a clean super
sheer glow your skin just looks so alive
check out eliabeauty.com and get 15 off
using summer 15 at checkout valid from
may 20th to may 26th
las vegas now will be